[Music]
this week snow white and the huntsman
came out on dvd
oh yeah you were talking about it in
line i heard you
and the director's commentary track was
recorded before the movie was released
yeah and if you know anything about that
movie and what happened i think it's
pretty revealing commentary
welcome to the dvd commentary for snow
white and the huntsman i'm producer joe
roth and i'm director rupert saunders
and i'd really really like to have sex
with the star of this movie kristen
stewart god she's hot oh look at her
your wife can hear this oh no one
listens to these things
uh here she comes through the woods look
look at it god i loved it
this guy wanted to cut out because he's
not kristen stewart chris hemsworth is
actually a big part of the film we were
really lucky i didn't i didn't care this
tree is a metaphor for my penis the
penis i want to put into christian
scripture actually these guys are too
actually i believe this is a scene
really dedicated to the life of snow
white yeah whatever you say but you know
what you keep talking i'm gonna go have
sex with kristen stewart um
[Music]
[Applause]